yeah hello and welcome to this video the
em todos okay or i am told us they'd
probably go for the big clamp down with
f4c three and so on and a fairly good
line i think a six haha oh my god anyway
okay well i didn't want to eat during
this reopen after this nonsense you
might as well eat my god he plays
absolutely the same stuff regardless of
what i'm doing well that's okay I mean
it's got to send them let's do something
funky well write equals D 597 that might
not be even all that terrible 85 is a
weird move
now you can take f5 that's the problem
is form takes g6 takes here that doesn't
work at all now have this always problem
here on the diagonal maybe this one at
least to develop quickly
okay so if i take and go to eat maybe
I'm getting this back next move when
I've got if I detect quite often right
age for maybe or something like that I
am Bishop 6 there may be I'm still
hanging on here not fun exactly but then
could be okay so it just gives it back
probably four temples but here I mean
that's not bad Bishop look so it on a
two at a to this one where does it go
probably back or a four
d three medals should be a square from
the bishop yeah
b5 before the ambitious way to do it ok
I'm getting this first and then be 50
interesting that looks interesting ok I
think I have to take probably and then
go age 6 yeah I need a bit of space down
and then be four next yes sir King h7 is
possible ok so he just goes back yeah he
look no OPA plunder stuff let's not do
that hmm where to put it I can put it
only five 494 maybe of course and I can
just take there are only one and 63
others lips a bit of the lame this is
more interesting 92 94 could be good for
black yeah that's good for blacker
unless I'm blundering stuff it should be
and I've got pressure on if we have
Bishop h3r overlooked gypsy I still have
h5 whatever that's good probably have to
do that
the washing machine going so and yeah
King and just take it huh it's a temple
on the roof so what's going on if I
check him oops you won't know what's
your move let's take it okay see one I
guess yeah ok so this and then you will
take the look I guess so anything else I
can do as no trickery his King position
is a little bit ly cash if I do this at
least you have to self pinned in the
case of a capture so this is our
medicine it's not really dangerous elkin
I was there for stupid hoe ok clink was
pretty stupid
time morning
I wanted on wanted to go to the second
rank it should be pretty okay there
should be
ok
I don't I can't get the g3 porn
unfortunately no my look all I have to
check first great Black Raven and there
has to be a way to lose the game it was
probably the only way run der fluke yeah
wow I really after this mouse slip in
the opening I really count to a good
position there and throw it away like
that I mean here's just a question I
mean white is struggling here but ok and
the engine gives equal so PP somehow is
still ok even though the night is on b1
and everything yeah it's probably still
very drawers we should be for one very
clever of course yet it is still going
to be in wrong in the normal
circumstances ok would be one would be
2008 call so here would be even better
yeah okay I didn't have much time and
I'm okay with the draw yeah I mean
that's not but it's okay it can check
first and then move the bishop I'm never
losing the same yeah yeah happens
unfortunately thanks for watching